une des missions du Muséum d'histoire
naturelle c'est avant tout une mission
scientifique c'est-à-dire que le Muséum
peut être sollicité par des pouvoirs
publics comme l'adéal pour faire des
expertises scientifiques et techniques
sur le terrain il s'agit en fait de
déterminer dans le dans l'antomophone la
faune les insectes s'il y a des insectes
patrimoniaux endémiques rares protégés
et
donc des déterminer s'ils sont présents
sur des sites bien précis défini par les
pouvoirs publics récemment j'ai été à
Mayotte donc pour une mission
d'échantillonnage des insectes
comment de fait par la délal du Mayotte
le but étant de d'aller collecter des
insectes pour pouvoir sur le court terme
définir des zones protégées ou à
protéger
après un travail donc de tri au
laboratoire les insectes sont classés
rangés dans des boîtes de collection
donc il y a un numéro d'inventaire par
spécimen un numéro d'inventaire par
boîte et chaque boîte correspond à une
famille particulière d'insectes et à une
provenance en l'occurrence dans le cas
de Mayotte à la provenance Mayotte elles
peuvent être utilisées pour remplir
d'autres missions du Muséum à savoir une
démission culturelle et pédagogique
notamment grâce à la diffusion
l'échange de connaissances scientifiques
actualisée et tout ça on se base sur des
expositions et des animations qui
elles-mêmes se basent sur les
collections d'insectes